he's holding on but for how much longer
wounded by last night's election results
Benjamin Netanyahu lashed out against
the threat of a coalition against him in
after we established a right-wing block
only two options are left either a
government under my leadership or a
dangerous government dependent on the
Arab parties at this time more than ever
especially with the tremendous security
challenges we face a government reliant
on the Arab anti Zionist parties must
not be formed we will make every effort
to prevent the creation of this
dangerous government's general Benny
godsey's blue and white party did
surprisingly well in these elections he
now has the momentum even if there was
no outright Viktor Benjamin Netanyahu is
now worse off after this election than
he was after the last one
six months ago close observers say he's
in trouble he set the bar at getting a
majority for his bloc of parties and he
failed and this is broken spell of
literally how the BB has been called for
so many as the magician and now the
magician seems to be just a confidence
trickster on the streets of Jerusalem it
seems Bibi as they call him he's losing
his mojo with voters
I hope he's finished I think that he's
reach the point where he is busy
thinking about himself and not thinking
about the country I definitely I
definitely supported him in the past
this time I would not go true I am very
sorry because very good criminal what is
it do you think baby is is finished it's
over for no I don't do so keep going
yeah
Bibi is a very strong nobody can finish
with Bibi analyst stress it's too early
to write off Netanyahu completely but
this could prove pivotal for the region
it's a huge moment in all in all kinds
of potential repercussions maybe
Israel's Arab neighbours the hostile
ones are saying to themselves this is
fantastic that Netanya was a blooming
nightmare maybe in Tehran they're
sitting there thinking wow this is going
to be great now we're gonna have a much
easier time trying to get a nuclear
weapons arsenal I mean the fallout from
this is potentially incredibly dramatic
yahoo faces criminal proceedings and
allegations of corruption we fought them
by attacking the police the courts and
media but none of that seems to be
working
he now faces the possibility not just of
being thrown out of power but then into
jail